[Music]
if you ever love me
if you ever love me
have mercy oh my God
[Applause]
he's sweet Gwen Stefani brought to tears
on The Voice
I'm trying to live in the moment during
Monday's final knockout round while
watching her hubby Blake Shelton's team
perform when got emotional as 16 year
old Braden lape took the stage to sing
Mercy by Brett young
just break it all right
[Music]
Gwen was moved to tears
have mercy
are you in loving them he's so sweet
Braden I there's something so
understated about what you do and it's
just so natural I just wanted to say
that as a mom that I think that you're
really good well thank you we're just
here to sort of download like our
experiences and you know try to see how
we can help and that's just I think at
this point in my life has been just
super rewarding but Gwen wasn't the only
coach gushing over Braden Camila Cabello
predicted he's got a whole new audience
after that performance
I think your tone is so beautiful and
has like an emotional innocence about it
I know like every girl's falling in love
with you right now
and his coach Blake was equally Blown
Away Brayden you chose a song that there
was nowhere to hide in that's scary you
get in the zone and it's so good and I
don't think you've sounded better I mean
everything was spot on and to No
Surprise the country singer decides to
send Brayden through to the live shows I
had to pick Brayden Braden is only 16
years old and he's already so good every
time he gets on the stage he's taking
huge steps so I think once we get into
the lobs it could be holding the trophy
at the end of this thing did you feel
more competitive or less competitive how
would you categorize it more or less
more competitive you got a win for the
household yeah and despite the natural
competition between the coaches Blake
still got full support from his wifey
Gwen especially as he prepares to exit
the singing competition after season 23.
I wasn't
[Music]
new Blake's gonna be right
um but I'm just so proud of him I mean
he's brought so much joy he's so
talented and I just I know people just
wait around to to laugh and watch him on
TV so I feel sorry for everybody he's
going to be gone and um yeah I just I
just I'm so proud of him
[Music]